ready ready yeah hey hey tastes welcome
to t a s t e buds wow this is this is a
a Monumental episode New Year this is
wild okay there's so many things to talk
about yes we're in the year of Our Lord
2024 okay we are in a new if you haven't
caught it we are in a new space um and
here's what you guys need to know
there's going to be a handful of
episodes in this space that we just
moved into but eventually in the next X
amount of weeks we are in the process of
redesigning the entire space giving the
entire Studio a complete facelift a
whole new look so we have up some
familiar things in the background but
stay tuned we will count it down but we
are really excited to transform this
studio into something that it's never
been before and there's going to be some
cool stuff involved in that yes yes it's
uh there's good energy so far in here it
feels good it feels right it feels like
we could probably scream at each other
in here and get away with it right yeah
well we're going to find out we're going
to find out because today is a heater
but um if not we might have to put up
some sound proofing some sound proofing
I say that like I know what I'm talking
about I just know you cut some foam into
squares and maybe you glue it onto the
wall but we'll get i'll Google it we'll
give it the egg crates yeah the egg
crates yeah yeah yeah yeah how hard
could could that be I'm not a
professional and this is the thing we
want this done professionally this time
you go down to Mattress Firm you buy
some Toppers and you Gloom to the W is
that really what that is no no no it
looks like it though I bet you it's
probably not that different of a
material yeah uh so okay a dense
Temperpedic material a dense Temperpedic
matal let me ask your question you have
a sleep in a tempic do you have one yeah
you have a you have one currently yes
okay I have one I've been a Temperpedic
fellow for quite some time now possibly
20 20 years possibly right yes did you
ever see the commercial where they put a
glass of red wine and a a stemmed glass
of red wine many times okay many times
and then they jump on it and then it
stays it's right where it is that's what
sold me on the mattress to begin with
that I could fall asleep with a glass of
wine and not knock out have you ever
tried it no no it seems insane to me it
seems insane right yeah yeah have you
done it I feel like I have but I don't
remember so I don't want to say that I
have but something like that wouldn't
get past me
normally I mean you could always just
fill a glass of water in a fill a wine
glass with water and then you could just
try it you sometimes I feel like you are
ignorant and dense and I sometimes I
feel like you uh you know are not like a
prant dense person but I mean I I just
feel sometimes I have these emotions
toward you as is the nature of our show
and then sometimes you just blow my
mind and for 20 years I didn't think to
put water in a in a in a wine glass and
do that I I got to be honest I it didn't
hit me till right now uh for whatever
reason I just finally realized you you
don't have to put wine into the glass so
here's what's going to here's what's
going to happen tonight here's what's
going to happen tonight okay when we
retire here when you get home and I'm
home you're going to call me we're going
to get a stemmed wine glass we're going
to put water in it we're going to put it
on our beds get on our beds together on
and we're going to and we're going to
selfie video this and jump up and down
and we're going to test it out
simultaneously all right okay all right
all right all right I let's try it let's
try it we now let me say love to get a
vote here actually
V can you put up on um on the taste bud
site uh if you know just word it in a
way like if we put our glass of red wine
on a Temperpedic mat mattress and jump
up and down how many of you think and
they just like it would spill it would
not spill you know what I'm saying now
let me say this big shout outs to
Temperpedic I had Temperpedic I love
tempic all through my time in Los
Angeles that was my first temp you put
that mattress to good use out there yes
hey and then I moved back here and when
I moved back here in the New York Groove
I switched from
Temperpedic to a certain bed brand that
involves a number oh okay I don't want
to say the name because I hate the bed
so much the blank the the the Number bed
you want to call it the blank Number bed
or the Sleep blank bed the Sleep blank
bed okay or the blank Number bed yeah I
hate it we you just don't want anyone to
know what we're talking about I hate it
it doesn't I don't think it works I
heard big J sing its Praises big J and
Christine I heard that he's he's firm
she's soft and they could coexist I you
know there's I have a theory about that
Jay is you have a theory about Jay and
Christine's mattress why Jay likes that
bed okay pleas he's white trash
and I sure if he would deny it but he
wouldn't he would fully agree with me I
I think I I think Jay is scholarly
[Music]
shut I really do he's a very smart guy
he is a smart guy you think trash can't
be smart oh I gu you heard of blue
collar philosopher you know like name
one like a Charles Bukowski guy was
brilliant him blue he was a beat yeah
not noow was a drunk he was a drunk yeah
yeah but he was smart yeah he's smart
but drunk doesn't mean you're trash I
would go as far as to say might have
been a little you think all drunks are
trash well I don't think of myself as
trash but uh you know uh uh you know uh
no I I'm kidding I think what's your
favorite
Bukowski I don't understand the
question what's your favorite
Bukowski what the hell does that mean
Charles Bukowski yeah what's my favorite
Bukowski yeah what do you mean like book
if you took a while guess what do do you
think book I've never read any of them
oh okay have you read Bukowski's books
I've read a couple I never read any of
them back it up thank you are they good
uh yes but I saw the movie particular
style what's that I saw the movie Barfly
okay where Mickey R played him okay yeah
I remember that one from the early ' 80s
yeah and I watched the documentary about
him I remember seeing as a kid and I
didn't know it was about Charles wowski
actually um
anyway I'm kidding about J being trash I
used to dat I used to date someone that
was a Bowski fan okay and I got them a
first edition of one of his books
autographed okay I thought that was nice
what was that worth it was I it was like
it was like hundreds oh that's it there
were different levels of I thought
that'd be like $10,000 or something no I
think his his autograph is out there
okay I did did she appreciate it well I
didn't say it was she
[Music]
I I actually regretted that I didn't do
the what's his name yeah but yes I
believe she did all right this this was
moons ago though moons hell of a gift we
we got off track what were we talking
about right now I was making a joke that
J was trash tell me if I was joking
there my that was my whole theory was
Jay Dre so he likes the the bed that you
can buy at the mall uh that's all I was
just making I was going to make a joke
about that but but no the bed in my
opinion first of all
stopped working oh [__] I said the real
name I said I didn't want to do that
well just be B it Stevie B it babe oh
Stevie
Baby I was biting my time going hit you
we're going to hit you with a real
Humdinger here Ste Steve's first I guess
now's the time to do it then just bleep
welcome to the bleep everything Joe says
podcast yes happy to be here you think
I'm bad you weren't here when Tommy Pope
was here no I dear Lord it was
it was every other word had to be bed it
was crazy he's so funny I saw um a short
film that him and Joe listed did you see
that one no I heard it's really funny oh
it's so great they're they're both so
funny really good in it um so anyway
Duty was that the one yes it was so
Steve Chone wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait let me just finish about the
bed real quick wow this is what he's
going to do on your first ever mention
because we're never going to get it done
and then this is what happens let's hold
let's hold on a big part of the podcast
my remote stopped working oh and I REM
like a hospital bed where it's like has
the wire I think the cheap one has that
no mine was full wild Bluetooth remote
and then also after a while it just
started to feel like you were on a
glorified air mattress I'm not a fan of
the bed I also got the split side I got
the split side thing like I sleep fine
on I have one in new it's been New York
but here's the thing when I bought my
his
nowe bought your what my his house my
house my his
house all right wait where did the nend
come from I just they couldn't remember
how to do
it it's his house I couldn't remember
his nouse I couldn't remember it was you
said when I when I got my his
nowe mistake uh so I had to you know cuz
I still have my apartment in New York so
I kept the Sleep Number bed in New York
and I went when I bought the bed for the
house I went back to tempering wow it's
the best decision I've ever made in my
life wow yeah yeah I mean we stand
Temperpedic and that is the bed tonight
that I will be jumping on with a glass
of that's the one water wine so we
listen this is the first time they could
actually do something wrong if that
thing goes down it's marketing was no
good but I will tell you I will tell you
there's no way these glasses aren going
to tip over there's no way there's no
way right there's no way I be I'm going
to do it on my side of the you might
have a higher end tempered than I do
that might play into it too well there's
a whole Suite of tempic mattresses and
now they have the cool and they have the
soft and the firmus and that I love them
so much I went from one tempic to
another and then I got my parents temper
pedics those are two different
households there and I got my
grandmother a temped I got five temp
pedics in the
family so Steve Chone yes sir welcome
the podcast list
all right here's what would here's as
you guys know or maybe you don't know um
homeless pimp uh has moved on from the
podcast we love him we wish him well
he's got a bunch of projects in the
pipeline and all good things you know
come to an end and uh you know we we we
we wish him well and so we now have to
go forward with uh a new team player
here and after a bunch of consideration
we have netted out with Steve Chone and
I'm looking at you see and I'm I'm
really getting to know Steve really
right now as well uh to a certain extent
I we really have don't have any history
together yeah and you will be now I mean
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
hours of conversations with us Chris
Chris you came to us through Chris the
pig the Stephano he recommended you
highly then AA sent a message to all of
us I think it said if you hire that
scumbag I'll
walk anyway
uh we don't know where it came from
um anyway we're all here's over there
Steve's over we don't know what you guys
what the issues you guys have are but we
we will get into it at some point table
wasn't big enough I would have
said Steve you you have informed me that
you are a comedy fan and previously you
were a fan of was it both I got I got
the God bless right on the on the you
have stickers from the Pod yeah right on
there well no not from the pod that's
your oh God blesses my my God blesses my
solo merch you have that yeah yeah yeah
how did you get that just went to your
store and got it you're kidding me I'm a
fan I'm a fan guys I was a fan of Chris
before I started working with you
believe he asked this question how did
you get my merch that I put out for sale
how do you think he got I I didn't
suspect that he went and purchased it
properly yeah I I give feel special the
kids got New York comedy club stickers
on there too that's true yeah I work
there as well you'll he'll have a word
with you later no I'm kidding let me get
a joey roses sticker on there they're my
favorite I love those I'm just joking
obviously I make I make of the ones I
love J White Trash all right that's the
coolest thing you purchased that sticker
I feel honored yeah uh what size shirt
are you uh small all right I'm going to
hook you up I'm going to hook you up
with some shirts I don't want to be
presumptuous but we'll get you around
the shirts from all the pods and some
solo stuff small how's that make me feel
it made me feel bad about myself oh I I
already felt bad I can't do any if you
want to do a medium if it makes you feel
better I can do yeah cuz you know M pre
shrunk I deal in very good materials um
but uh listen you were a fan of the
podcast so you understand where we came
from what we are what we do here you
know pimp you fan of pimp probably
absolutely you know this the the kind of
vibe that we cultivated here and we're
passing the torch along to you I got to
tell you I feel a
tremendous positive energy from you I
feel very positive energy from uh from
you it's emanating off of you you're
wearing a smile right now and it's a
it's a it's a if I might say so myself
it is a very nice smile it's a nice
smile it's a kill a smile you got a good
jaw you got you got good Chompers and
you you go with a a mustache with did
you notice this not to steal your
thunder I I kind of shaved this off for
now I was going mustache prominent which
I was about to say you're mustache
forward even though you have some some
Shadow that's the only thing that grows
oh you're beard shorter I thought you I
shed it to nothing it just growing back
now oh okay I thought you trim down 12
years 12 years yeah you good with that
didn't even notice I thought you just
trimmed it down there's still a full
beard on your face no there's not this
is a a half George Michael at
best for you maybe but I'm telling you
for the guy like me that's a full beard
for a guy like you what kind of guy are
you I'm saying if I had that much hair
on my face I would consider myself
bearded that's what I'm saying no
V you think I have a beard right now a
little one this is like this is that's
there's no such thing as a little beard
it's a beard or it's not a beard if not
it's just stubble it's a beard wow yeah
it's a beard buddy you got a beard I'm
sorry tomorrow will definitely be a
beard maybe it's a stub right now I'm
looking a little closer yeah look at I
understand compared comment in the
comments yeah you think this is a beard
or a stub I would go stub yeah I would
too stub that's bet the mustache is a
little thicker but the the mustache I
left yeah yeah yeah um listen where you
from Steve Long Island Ridge yeah what
part uh Lake Ron
cona Lake won
cona bro I can't believe you're from
there Beach Boy song kook
that those are Tropical Islands this is
Long Island that wasn't about Island
little place like Ron I like it Ron so I
went up to montalk this past weekend and
I passed the Rono Ron yeah Ron conama
sign going and coming and besides
skincity Ron conama is my favorite town
is city yeah in it's my favorite name I
I mean you say Ron no matter where you
are you can't be upset saying Ron cona
no it's fun fun and I love asking people
like I would sometimes we would on the
show ask people you have get up to Rona
because it's just so much fun so you've
gotten to say I'm from Rona your whole
life yeah and is it pleasurable or by
now are you like I can't take s cuz cuz
the people that don't know Ron cona are
like what or the people that you know
what I mean like are they like well
where do people ask you how what's Ron
cona I think they they they're familiar
because the last stop on the L stop that
yeah so you fall asleep on the train
drunk you'll wind up in run I never
heard of it till today it's a magical
place where drunks wake
up it sounds like it's so far from here
it is I think it's like like 6 70 miles
something like that what was it like
growing up around was you know suburbs
it was fun the commitment don't glaze
over the commitment the kid is traveling
70 miles no that's not why you live now
yeah Steve yeah I I moved back from La
in 2010 so I'm back in Rona oh so you're
coming from Ron cona when you come here
yeah oh babe yeah this is I'm doing it
for the babes this is dedication I had
no idea that's a yeah I mean depending
on when we do it too you got to hit that
you got to hit the belt yeah no buddy
you can't do that I'm doing it babe if
we'll see if I'll set when this is set
up if you ever need to crash here you
can oh no ier to yeah he needs to I
might need to crash here no Stevie Chone
from Rona Steve from Rona first time
long time there he is Steve from Ron
cona um I I am excited to have you uh
it's cool that you know the show and
that you're a fan of the show because
you'll fold right in you obviously then
no Vena our diamond in the rough over
here right and uh and you're with Chris
on his other pod now uh no so I I tour
manage with him oh you right you tour
manage right oh yes yes yes yes
excellent wow and my manager Amelia New
York comedy club
proprietor uh is very you know you guys
have done stuff together oh sure yeah I
mean I manage at the club as well yeah
yeah so he uh he spoke very highly of
you to me on New Year's Eve when I saw
him awesome yeah highly on New Year's
Eve how was your New Year's Eve by the
way it was good good it was relaxed so
with some good company small group and I
realized Steve S asked you many more
questions about yourself than I did I'm
going to keep going I don't I don't mix
with the help where we at bye come on
nothing on that I'm sorry I was I want
to make sure where we're atar you can't
talk over a mean joke like that do it
again do it again I'll make believe I
didn't I said all right retake ready
yeah Steve yeah I realized I didn't ask
you as many questions about you as s did
but I I don't mix with the
[Music]
help all right as as you're wearing
whatever jacket that is you like this
jacket a twill Tweed what is that you
got a large collar up top it's a scotch
and sod babe oh a scotch and soda
favorite brand for Jack that's nice
that's a little old yeah do you like
this jacket can you stand up yeah I got
it I bought it for myself oh my God it's
a three4 length it's a 3/4 length that
you got on with with some gray denim
right now and a t-shirt the T-shirt
under a 3/4 length twill Overcoat is
bold well that wasn't the outfit it's
just it's freezing in here because I
don't something's wrong with you you
know we can close we can close the uh uh
uh but then I figured I'll take this off
and then the next how long you doing
that
jacket since December 24th I bought it
on Christmas Eve this is a new jacket in
cuz I haven't seen it I went I needed a
new a Christmas Eve purchase it has a
special beginning this isn't a peaco but
my peat has on its last legs I needed a
peacat style Jack I got two peats and I
went to the mall with my dear friend Jim
pinkstone on Christmas Eve as you do
morning a pink Stone's known for
Christmas Eve sh oh yeah and uh and we
bought a few things and one of the
things I bought was this coat sale full
price full price but reasonably price
okay I wish would even said that why
because I like to play games and I'm
about to play a guessing game on your
coat I would never say the price on air
you're saying the price on it no it's a
coat you bought a coat you're an adult
you have a job it was New Year's Eve
it's a nice coat you're allowed to buy
why would you never say the price on was
it a $40,000 coat you guessed it you hit
it right on the head well we all going
to take guesses and whoever comes okay
this is what we're doing okay wait V I
have a scratch off in my bag right there
okay can you in the top in the front
pouch of that backpack right there I got
a couple of lottery tickets and uh real
ones and two Scratch R that I never
checked so we be sitting on billions um
top front top top front top is that the
top top front yeah top front and right
right right in there somewhere it's
probably a scratch off and some some
loty tickets yeah so how does this tie
into okay well first things first we'll
take the lottery tickets we'll put them
on the side I'll have someone look these
up uh eventually cuz this is just to
build tension cuz we may be we may be
multi multi we I may be but I you guys
you guys will you guys will benefit okay
okay but here here are these three so we
have three we're going to play guessing
games throughout this one the first
guessing game is closest to your coat
don't worry about going over just
closest to your coat whoever wins out of
what do the tickets do with this though
I don't understand well whoever gets
closest gets the scratch off oh it gets
the prize yeah you got to just connect
the dots a little faster today I mean I
don't I have no chance of winning the
prize though no not at all but you you
do well for this particular question you
cannot win the prize you know the price
okay all right yes all right all right
this is just we're we having group fun
now okay see by the way before today or
before the next couple of weeks I will
have 500 nicknames for you just know
that okay what what is CHR Chris
mentioned Steve Steve Chone reron yeah
reron chicone uh Chone Stevie pedals uh
why Stevie pedals just driving to the
next city car
pedals I don't call you call them pedals
I guess oh yeah GED pedal to the metal I
guess I just don't call them I don't
don't I don't think it pedals on cars
yeah uh all right let's let's get the
guessing going um do you want to say
them out loud or do you want to just
write them like what do you want to do
here oh that's a good idea I can say do
we all have our numbers and just be H I
got a number I got a number okay cool be
honest I got a number okay all right I
I'll have a reron chicone lead it off
and and we're and we're saying it we can
say it you can to say it I'm going to go
with 650 Bob whoa
wow Ron going high that's yeah Ron okay
uh can we you know what I should have
asked this person can we can I get a a
material please o no I think that's not
fair cuz Steve guess I'll let him guess
again it looks like a wool I think we
have a guess what's this type some type
of wool there
100% you didn't even you don't even know
you don't know what you're wearing you
have a draped all over your body I
assumed it was wool it's got a very nice
let's can you can we see the inner yeah
it's a nice lining and it's lined all
the way this satiny material it's lined
all the way down the sleeves oh that's
very nice which which was a big plus and
where do you see yourself wearing this
I'm just day to day day to day yeah
you're going to make that a day that
that's going to become your casual
day-to-day this is replacing my peacat
that was on it way out w wow a 3/4
length at all times you know what you
know what can I tell you a little story
we were standing in the department store
reporters do that only we were standing
in the department store where I
purchased this and I said I said I think
this could replace my peaco as my dayto
day and my friend Jim said Jim pinkstone
yeah he said I don't know man that's
kind of a flashy pattern I don't think
that's a dayto day and I said why can't
it be and he said all right it's 2024
babe why can't a flashy pattern be the
dayto day I don't think it's that flashy
I think what puts it over the top is 3
quarter length yep is it double
rested what does that mean again yeah
buttons across yeah it is like a peacat
yes okay so it's quite warm it is quite
warm okay but also strangely
light yeah it's versatile Dan between
the you stay in with 650 I'm going to
stay with 650 650 stay in come on my
number is 300
300 okay less than half I was going to
say 300 okay and where are you from
originally from the city what city in
New York New York City yeah New York
City proper correct okay we got Ron con
New York City yeah okay grew up on the
Upp Wesson in Queens there you go I'm
going to go with my original guess was
395 o I think 300
was I feel like they don't do rounds
numbers like that but anyway no big deal
I'm saying 395
[Laughter]
um uh and and did you charge
this no I paid I mean I used my debit
card but no I did not charge I paid I
paid for that that code's paid for now
it's paid for you don't walk you don't
ow nothing on that coat I wouldn't have
done it I'm trying to be careful with
the charges okay excellent I love it for
2024 always always I've got myself into
trouble in years past and uh I tried to
really be responsible about it would you
buy like a whole bunch of coats I bought
I don't know what I bought to be honest
I bought a lot of stuff all right you
got yourself to trouble charging up just
a ton of 3/4 length coats yeah yeah
whole whole closet folks all right you
got a drum roll are we all any of us in
the ballpark yeah is any are any of us
very close yeah okay okay I got news for
you yeah
whoa right in the middle wow right in
the middle I almost said 3 well I almost
went low but you said a lot so 395 so 45
away you're 50 away I'll tell you what
I'll tell you what you win it's coming
off a fresh holiday season you take one
of those right now you scratch it off
live on the air if you win which
whatever which one is it you going to do
take one one for life okay how about
this if you win for life we split it
sounds great but the other half's yours
Steve I want you with a Win For Life
ticket in your hand by the end of
this folks there's a big stressor out
there and it's called erectile
dysfunction it just stresses people out
it's something that people find very
awkward to address or to talk about and
that is why hymns is here to help okay
Real Talk 52% of men over the age of 40
experience some form of Ed that's
erectile dysfunction between the ages of
40 and 70 but it's always been taboo as
I said thankfully hymns is changing that
by providing affordable access to ed
treatment all online you can be
confident in the office you can be
confident at the dinner table you can be
confident on that dance floor uh keep it
going the confidence you're going to
keep it going to where to back to the
bedroom you know what I'm saying with
hyns you can get access to medications
to ensure your Ed gets treated so you
can keep the confidence going all day
long do you hear what I'm saying people
do you see the theme Here I know that
you do anyway Hy is changing Men's
Health Care by providing this access
again it's affordable it is discreet for
sexual health treatments and it's all
done from wear the comfort of your couch
okay they are going to provide you with
clinically proven generic alternatives
to Viagra and Calis up to 95% cheaper
with options as low as $2 per dose the
process is simple again it's 100% online
and there are no uncomfortable doctor's
visits it's all discreet there's no
insurance needed that's it here's how
you do it you're going to start your
free online visit today at hs.com
tastebuds that's hms.com tastebuds for
your personalized ed treatment options
hs.com
tastebuds prescriptions require an
online consultation with a healthc care
provider who will determine if
appropriate restrictions apply see
website for details and important safety
information subscription required price
varies based on product and subscription
plan folks let's talk about factors
ready to eat meals
that make eating every day easier and
even better why cuz they're delicious
they're convenient they're fast and they
are affordable wherever tomorrow takes
you be ready with pre-prepared Chef
crafted and dietician approved meals
delivered right to where your front door
you're going to have over 35 different
options a week to choose from with
Factor including keto options calorie
smart vegan and veggie and more and
there's even more to enjoy with a over
55 nutrition packed add-ons that help
make your weekly meal planning even more
delicious thank you factor so what are
you waiting for folks get started today
and have a feel-good week of meals ready
to go these are two-minute meals so you
can fuel up fast with Factor's
Restaurant quality Goods snacks
smoothies and more discover a wide
variety of easy options for the entire
day like breakfast midday bites and more
you're going to sign up and save we've
done the math factor is less expensive
ensive than take out and every meal is
dietitian approved to be nutritious and
delicious so head toctor meals.com
tastebuds 5 and use code taste buds 5 to
get 50% off your first box and two free
wellness shots per box while
subscription is active Okay that's code
tastebuds 50@ Factor meals.com taste
buds 5 to get 50% off your first box and
two free wellness shots per box while
subscription is active this show is
sponsored by betterhelp taste buds
sponsored by betterhelp well here's the
thing with better help they're fantastic
why let's talk about relationships for
example one of the relationships in my
life that I'm most proud of is my
relationship with my parents and it is a
complicated relationship and the reason
I am so proud of that relationship is
because there were turbulent times in
that relationship and what did I do and
what did my parents do in order to try
to improve that relationship and
navigate those turbulent times we went
to therapy individually and together I'm
not kidding I'm not making that up we
did it we did the work and it made our
lives and our lives with each other even
better and that's that's the kind of
thing therapy can do for you okay the
common misconception about relationships
is that there're they're supposed to be
easy and if they're easy then they're
right and that's not the truth sometimes
great relationships can happen when both
people put in the work to make them
right and that's exactly what I'm
talking about better help can help you
do that if you're thinking about therapy
give better help a try okay I've
benefited from this and I want to tell
you that whether or not you've been in
therapy okay uh it can really be the
thing for you okay there are great
benefits to this uh it's it's it's not
just allowing you to work on the
relationships with others but it's it's
allowing you to work on the relationship
with yourself and that is going to lead
to an easier and better relationship
with others and again a relationship
ain't always easy takes work sometimes
and there's nothing wrong with that
better help can help Okay so become your
own soulmate whether you're looking for
one or not visit betterhelp.com
tastebuds today and get 10% off your
first month that's better help HP /
tastebuds folks do you like to chill and
relax do you like to be calm do you want
to get rid of that soreness do you want
to sleep easier well the folks at mood
have some things some products you might
want to look into all right social
THC all right that social THC high you
can get how by using moods eoric social
or erotic products all right uh s is a
big fan of mood um and he's a big fan of
it for many reasons number one it's
federally legal THC which is great uh
and now they're adding their most potent
product yet to the lineup introducing
hemp-based thca flow the future of legal
THC try to get it along with mood's
other amazing offerings like their
gummies and their Vape cartridges and
more they've got all kinds of stuff and
for a limited time mood is giving
listeners a free
thca pre-roll in % off your first order
just visit hood.com and use code
tastebuds um Salis told me uh that he
finds mood's products quite calming as I
said and they help greatly with the
chill and the relax or the Chilla if you
would say and I like their products
because they calm him down quite frankly
people you've seen what I deal with on
this show it's nice to have him a little
you know uh anyway he he said socially
whether that is hanging out with one or
another person or in a group of people
he's enjoyed it quite quite quite a bit
um since the
thca by the way converts into THC when
you heat it you can get access to that
classic marijuana high and mood also has
10 high inducing strains the which is
you know the most potent they've ever
offered okay mood puts an end to the
guessing games also with federally legal
again that's really important federally
legal for forms of THC extracted from
hemp plants all of their products are
regularly third-party tested and Drug
Enforcement Agency registered Labs
they're sourced from small family farms
and grown organically so anyway try
mood's new THC flower today and for 20%
off your first order and a free thca
pre-roll go to hello.com and use promo
code taste buds that's h e l l o m o
o.com hello m o o o.com use code taste
buds for 20% off your first order and a
free thca pre-roll um we should start
the battle we should let's go for it
baby yeah uh we are battling today we
want it to come out of the gate well
actually we don't know if this will be
the first episode or not back but if it
it probably should be at this point
because we're meeting Steve and
everything so we wanted to uh really
kick things off with a bang and I
suggested this battle earlier V looked
it up we found out that it is an ongoing
battle amongst the people uh of this
great country our of ours it's already
it's already has has it already has its
own yeah history and I said well then
that's great s agreed it is trisc versus
wheat th Triscuits versus Wheat Thins uh
I am team Triscuits of course I am
course I'm team Triscuits Triscuits can
I sh team we and let's get it popping
you know what we haven't done it in a
while let's do it no matter what happens
okay a I love it good to see you again
happy New Year happy New Year no matter
what happens I love you no matter what
happens I love you no matter what
happens I love you time to b a t t l e
bus all right team Triscuits what were
you just going to ask me you were going
to ask me a real snotty little question
about triset I was going to ask where
does name trisket come from we we we we
re realized before it's a play on
biscuit but what's TR what's the try
trist no that's all right can we get a
atmology on Triscuits I'm guessing that
it's try like try meaning meaning three
types of grain or whatever like you know
okay well let's find out yes that's what
it is it is wow and that was a guess yes
that was a guess yes right maybe that
new coat has superpowers elevated me
yeah but wait but what I don't
understand is why play on the word
biscuit it's from you're right about the
three but it's a reference to the three
ingredients used wheat oil and salt
that's it okay is that all they do wheat
no that's not true it's why it's a
tremendous if I had a bunch of wheat
here with oil and salt I couldn't make a
Triscuit it's it says it is reference to
the three ingredients used that's what
just wheat germ that's it so first of
all easy with your wheat I'm Wheat Thin
if anyone's taking over the wheat Market
it's brother first of all ain't nothing
thin about Wheat Thins except the the
fact that the cracker is is skinny so
everything about
it is there is there about the we is
there outside of the rits which it
tastes good but is a disgrace to
crackers don't bring theit into this the
RIT is a disgrace to Cracker outside of
I don't believe it is is there another
cracker that undercuts Cracker more than
a wheat I mean it tastes like you're
eating M&M's they are so sweet you're
going on on a Wheat Thin taste yeah
they're too sweet you going to be you're
alone you're you're on an island alone
on this sweet they're too sweet sweet
sweet thins are too sweet th a you have
a standard flavored Wheat Thin and
that's sweet V give me a sugar added
sugar count on wheat thins please
regular also give me give me if you can
uh how many flavors does Wheaten have
and how many flavors does Triscuit have
give give us a nutrition fact comparison
actually so for the sugars in one
serving is
2.61 uh Gams of whe thins for weins how
many added sugars 2.61 is nothing all
right still something how many in
Triscuits in
Triscuits it is I don't think they have
well it shouldn't be any right it's salt
that's what I'm salt oil and there
shouldn't be sugar in crackers crackers
don't need sugar that's yeah they don't
have thank you oh is that why they is
that why they taste like packing foam
yeah please outside of a grape nut and a
shredded mini wheat the wheat then is
the worst the trisuit you mean sorry the
Triscuit is the worst textured edible
aming product I've ever tasted it feels
like you're putting a wicker chair in
your mouth it's an amazing texture the
Wheat Thin against a I mean I'm sorry
the the Triscuit against a piece of
cheese is marvelous it's marvelous and
here's what's great about a Triscuit
it's a little bit fun cracker Nostalgia
because you get it still in that grocery
aisle and all that stuff but it's it's
an elevated cracker it has a little clas
to it it's a little refined a Wheat Thin
is is for it's for children the Wheat
Thin it's for children it's it's a
cracker that a child can eat because it
tastes like sugar it tastes like sugar
and you know that it does you know that
it does are you telling me I'm wrong are
you telling me a wheat th doesn't taste
any say a cracker it does not and that
just shows me you don't really know
anything about weens do you you how when
was the last time you bought or had a
ween when a year ago a year ago you had
a ween and a year ago you went this
feels too sweet for me yes at 2.6 sugars
in an entire serving you felt that that
was too sweet I have picked them off the
shelf when I am hosting a party and put
them back and said I'm not doing you
could use a gallon of sugar a Triscuit
again it feels like you're eating an
Easter basket okay it's terrible it is
dry it breaks up in your mouth like it's
brittle and still like a cracker
supposed to like it's brittle like it's
brittle and stale no one I've never ever
met a person who liked a Triscuit oh
that's I swear to you I've never seen
Steve beep it I've never seen a Triscuit
in someone's home in in the wild I've
only seen Triscuits you've been to my
home you've seen them I got a I got a
box of Triscuits in my
covered
steadily steadily I got one in both of
my homes right now in the cover sorry
guys $350 3/4 length wool coat two homes
and he doesn't speak to the help okay
and he eats Triscuit Tris for the better
half
right if Tris you're saying Triscuits
and weens were on the Titanic you're
taking the Triscuits off you're leaving
the Wheaten on the Titanic y you know
honestly Joe trisket is in the same
family as a grap nut as a mini shred no
that's not true it is it's it's if ran
became edible it's a it is a substantial
it is disgusting cracker it is a
substantial cracker it's like eat it's
it's it's got the sustenance of like
almost like a bread or something it's a
heavy is a cracker is it a bread is it a
biscuit I'm saying it's got the
sustenance of a of a bread the balls on
the Triscuit to use the CI at the end to
even put itself in the same sent
sentence as a biscuit a biscuit is one
of God's greatest Creations well
remember that when you battle me on it I
will because there's another creation
that's better than a biscuit but a
biscuit is something that the the
Triscuit was so bad it was like what is
an undeniable thing that everyone loves
that that that that I can just I could
just attach myself to that might give me
some Goodwill with the public because a
I mean really I'm here's what I want you
to do everybody when you go to the
supermarket next I want you to hover
around the cracker aisle if you can
spare 5 10 minutes okay if anybody buys
a Triscuit
whatsoever I mean every time you go to
the supermarket for the next month just
give five minutes to the Triscuit wheat
aisle okay if anybody picks anything up
know whether it's a Triscuit or a weat I
don't think anybody's buying a Triscuit
ever I don't think you'll ever see
anyone pick up a box of Triscuits at a
supermarket but if you do note the age
and please write to us at noes Network
gmail.com noes Network gmail.com and
write Triscuit sighting okay I guarantee
you everyone who buys TR talking like
everybody's walking around with wheat
thins but bro weins have crossed over
wein are like the Snoop Dog of crackers
oh no they are not yes yes they are even
don't even remember the last time I saw
we even Rich who is the The Buttery
Powerhouse of old has has actually taken
a back seat to a Wheaten because they
have come out of the gate now how many
flavors
be the flavors don't matter to me talk
the flavors Dred tomato you're talking
garlic and herb parmesan you think truit
doesn't have flavors it needs it they've
got flavors it needs it they've got
flavors so then it has more than just
salt oil and wheat no the flavored ones
do but I thought we were battling the
original flavors here I didn't know we
were going into other flavors if you
dare took a bite of a Triscuit without a
trough of water water near you please
you might pass you might pass on to the
next life I do it all you're going to
get Tri you know and it breaks into
shards you get you get Triscuit shrapnel
all over your trachea and esophagus you
think you don't get that with wein you
don't to get wein a prop snap I get
seeds stuck all through my teeth with
wheat thins there are no seeds on whe
thins ladies and gentlemen pull the
alarm are those things pull the alarm Am
I Wrong sound the siren they're
speckling on Wheats and I get it all
stuck in my tee this should be an a if
we were in on trial right now will be a
mistrial he doesn't even think he's not
even battling against a wein what do you
think you're battling against a sesame
stick byor show us the we seeds there
are no seeds on WE THS there's no crying
in baseball there no seeds on are Little
Speckled things all over the Wheat Thin
I thought they were seeds I don't know
what they are there's about 23 varieties
of Wheat Thins and we have um artisan
cheese Vermont white cheddar we have
Chipotle we have d
Pi God I wasn't even aware the wa no if
he's going to be like this let's do this
okay we'll know through all the flavors
of each we go fast you start with the
ween flavors go ahead and I I'll make a
comment on each one and I want you to be
real be real be honest just be honest go
ahead okay artisan cheese we have two
Wisconsin Kobe we have Vermont white
cheddar we have Chipotle we have dill
pickle Chipotle is disgusting Chipotle
is my first one I'm like dill pickle wow
no but it's dill pickle with Wheat Thin
flavor it's gross dill pickle potato
chip is awesome dill pickle Wheat Thin
flavor gross and you think you're
getting Artisan cheeses in a box of
these speckled crackers you're out of
your mind on seeds that don't exist you
do would you take mushrooms the last
time you had Wheat Thins where are you
getting seeds from tell me what the
speckling is on the Wheat Thin I'm not
crazy there's like little seeds or
something that's that's a futile search
my friend tell tell me what the
speckling is on the just just pull up
the picture ingredients it's probably
the the P the the it's probably the the
the you
know FL yeah the the uh what what
whatever it is I to I get it all in my
teeth it's probably the cheese that has
been granulated and dusted I don't eat
cheese flavored wheat THS well what do
you eat what is the one that you eat
brisket no but what Wheats did you eat
that had seeds what wheat THS did you
eat the regular Wheat Thins have like
speckled things on them that get stuck
in your teeth I think that day you just
didn't clean your specks yourself just
just pull up a box of eans and just show
us the picture and I'll point to what
I'm talking about enlarge it to show
texture here you go let's do it I mean
I'll point to what I'm talking about you
know you're on a you're on a plane right
now that ran out of fuel right
salt oh oh those salt
seeds oh it's oh look oh yeah it is look
at all the fine look at all the Sal
these things those are divots these
things those are divots in the Tris in
the in the wheat then those are divots
inside that's not a you hit your head on
the thing when you sat back yeah all
right that's something to look out for
in the
future go ahead I'm giving you the floor
would you like to talk about the seeds
now I am Telling You Wheat Thins have
Little Speckled things on them I don't
like the picture you just pulled up the
the the the approved Wheat Thins en
largey show texture I don't even know if
those were wheat THS we just looked at
oh you don't even know what a Wheat Thin
is d
[Music]
you don't even know what a weat th is I
do know what a we is little holes in the
cracker all right all right all right if
I'm going if I'm going to battle you
these battles need to be based in
reality Joe here's the thing a cracker
should not have any sugar in it period
that is not the purpose of a cracker
that's at the top of your Hill yes a
cook 2.6 g of sugar in a serving is why
you're going to throw
you know what I looked up once what's a
healthy snack for brain power I looked
this up there was a list I found on the
internet okay you know Google you know
one you know one of the top suggestions
was cheese and
Triscuits whole grain cracker with some
cheese let's be honest cheese is doing
the heavy lifting
there cheese is Triscuit Triscuit are
you eating a box of whe things by
themselves sometimes please depends on
the wheat that's my problem with them
that's what I'm saying that's my problem
with them is because they taste like
cookies oh now they taste like cookies
not cookies tast I stand by they taste
like graham crackers they taste like a
diet gram cracker Jo you and you think
Triscuits taste like what like crackers
no buddy buddy when you eat a Saltine do
you taste sugar do you taste sugar and a
Sal T it's not a sugar tetine it's a
Saltine exactly but it it's it doesn't
taste like sugary Saltine doesn't when
you get the when you get the water wafer
crackers whatever they're called come in
the Black Box the classiest of all
crackers that come in the long do you
want what I'm talking about which ones
those crackers that come in the long
black
sleeve yeah water cck the Water Crest
whatever they're called the we would
agree they're very the plain elegant of
most elegant of all
crackers they're they there is nothing
sweet about them they taste like a
cracker those crackers have nothing to
do with you being the only person who
feels that you taste the two grams of
sugar in it whole crackers should be
sweet crack should be reminiscent of 24
Savory flavors okay and I I tell you
what I like I like I like that even
though the wheat then I like that it is
th thin I love and it has a snap to it
oh it has no
snap they're chewy you no they're
not you stop it they don't have seeds
and then not chewy and they don't tast
my eye watch is ringing oh my God you
got the new I watch I'm so sorry and is
that the highest end model it is I don't
know you you you're putting on airs
you're coming into this new year and
you're taking this whole attitude and
you're putting it into the
battle I I don't E I wear a nice coat
and I got the eyew watch and I need
Triscuits yeah well just because you did
a makeover in one week doesn't mean look
that doesn't mean that that trisuits
already good dude so you're battling
you're saying guys let's just sum it up
he's saying wheatens have seeds and they
taste like cookies and they're mushy
okay I Say No Seeds they have a snap and
a half if I'm being honest they do not
have SN they do not taste like cookies
okay when you bite into a Triscuit do
you not is it not like Blackhawk Down in
your mouth is it not like is it not
trisuit shrapnel just popping off all in
there these little little little I will
admit sometimes you can get a little you
can get a little crumble but no I love a
Triscuit you talking about a snap a
Triscuits got snaap dude a Triscuit is a
fir Triscuit is the one that has a
little bit of a give in it it has does
not it is too it's weaved together it
does not have give trisuit is a firm
firm
cracker no yes it is oh God and the Tris
is better for dipping and adding to
because it's sugar BS isn't getting in
the way you don't even need to dip a whe
in okay you need God's help with a
I got to tell you I hate Mayo I would
I'd have to if I had just a b let me
tell you something right now if if the
[__] really hit the vanan and uh you
know something happened and I was low on
rations and the only thing left was
Triscuits I probably would just die the
need a Triscuit I probably would just
die peace I'm telling you something
buddy I'm telling you something right
now sorry spit a little water I'm
telling you something right now just Pat
it just Pat it off with your hand I am
cuz I don't have a towel the uh I'm
telling you something right now you
don't have a towel
oh
man I'm telling you something right now
you are not
supposed to eat
crackers by themselves crackers are
meant to be something that that is added
to with something else the problem with
wheat thins is that you can eat them by
themselves the problem with Rich
crackers is that you can eat them by
themselves it means there's a bunch of
crap in there that shouldn't be in there
that's making it function more like a
potato chip or something whe thins is is
doing flavors like it's potato how many
flavors does Triscuit have it's 2024 if
your product ain't doing flavors you
don't got a product look wheat does some
Flav or I mean Triscuit does some
flavors you know what trisuit flavors
are let's talk about
class hold on let's talk about class
ready for the difference in class good
flavors you you you you you you mess
with Triscuits I like Triscuits yeah you
do yeah can you please regil us with the
difference in the classiness of flavors
of Triscuits you heard the you heard the
nonsense wheat THS was ping Chipotle was
one of them yes you're right look top of
the list first their first flavor is
wool 3/4 length coat
Triscuit so there's um Cracked Pepper
and olive oil Cracked Pepper and olive
oil and you're coming with
Chipotle um there's hint of salt hint of
salt Rosemary hold hold on hold that's
you know why God forbid they go plain
God forbid they go plain they would ship
them off to other countries um Rosemary
and olive oil Dill sea salt and olive
oil D sea salt oh I love it so Triscuit
has a dill too and you just tore D to
shreds you said it tasted terrible said
it doesn't belong on a cracker you said
it belongs on a potato chip no no no you
know what Triscuit has Triscuit has a
dill sea salt and oil they don't not
it's not a dill pickle flavor and guess
what the wein has oil and salt in by
just by make being a I have news for you
if you gave me a Triscuit with a slice
of dill pickle on it I would eat it if
you give me a Wheat Thin With A Slice of
dill pickle on it I would go gross those
flavors don't match y you just got
caught red-handed you no what in the
cracker jar what I said was the flavor
is gross because it's mixed with Wheat
Thin flavor you shat on dill and lo and
behold and also Dill ain't dill pickle
bub Dy D pick by the way Rosemary Rose
well Dy and D pickle are two very
different things here's what you're
doing you're taking styrofoam and you're
trying to dress it up okay they had a
meeting they
said we can't just ship these out
willy-nilly plain so we need to go
overboard here what would what would
possibly save this did you just spill a
full water no I thought I did but I
didn't was my empty Snapp what would
possibly save this we need the finest of
ingredients to to to even move a unit of
this stuff that's not true B Triscuit
have been hitting Grand Slam dude you go
to the Cracker aisle s there's four
crackers there's four there's four
Titans in the cracker aisle Triscuits
Wheats saltin rits yeah even townhouse
is second fiddle these are your big four
I agree yeah Triscuits didn't need that
flavors to to play in the game Triscuit
has been playing Triscuit is the only
cracker I've ever heard referenced in a
movie Billy Madison well perhaps if you
had told me there were delicious
Triscuit crackers eatting the limousine
I wouldn't be hungry right now he didn't
say delicious wheat things that's a very
good argument you heard Triscuits in the
movie once and it's that means it's
better than the rest I say trisuit
Triscuit is at the end of The L I'm
saying we need a cracker to reference in
Adam Sandler's first and best movie
trisuit and trisuit let me let me show
you something right if I had a beautiful
retan chair right there and I threw on
some dill oil and a hint of salt and I
took a bite of it you know what it's
going to taste like a it's going to
taste like Rattan okay with oil and Sal
if I took a chipet cookie and added dill
pickle flavor to it it would be
disgusting it would be disgusting I'm
saying the dill pickle flavor isn't bad
it's it's bad cuz it's added to Wheat
Thin I don't believe when I'm looking at
you from across his couch after 3 years
of doing this I don't believe that you
believe your argument
buddy I will put you in my car and it's
time for me to start shooting straight
right now and I will drive you to my
home that I recently purchased and I
will show you an almost fully finished
box of Triscuits without a stitch of
cheese in the house that's not what I
said I just said I don't believe you're
argument believeing my argument I put my
money wear my mouths I I say you don't
have triset I didn't say you don't eat
Triscuits I eat them all the time I said
I don't believe your argument that's
that you think a wheat didn't taste like
a chips aoy that's vs I'm I'm speaking
colorfully my point is though is that a
Wheat Thin you your whole argument is
we're at 45 oh 48 okay we got to wrap up
okay all right my my closing argument is
is that you're saying a Wheat Thin is
great because it tastes so good by
itself and I am saying to you a cracker
shouldn't if it tastes that good by
itself then you're you're you're
lurching towards cookie territory that's
my argument that is the funniest thing
I've heard in a long time I want you to
olate that if you could eat a cracker by
itself you're lurching toward cookie
territory so his let's just let's just
be clear here cuz I'm going to reiterate
your point you just made and I'm going
to repeat it exactly but use it as a
point for me okay you just said the
statement that if a cracker is good
enough alone something's wrong with it
okay I just want to say that's what you
said that's what you just said so all
the crackers that are good enough to eat
without any autron are terrible no I eat
I eat Triscuit sometimes just playing by
themselves my point is though is you're
not going to make a meal out of it where
you're saying you could eat a box of
Wheat Thins and it's like yeah because
they got sugar in it and they're not
good for you dude look bread can be
delicious but you don't usually go oh I
love eating that white bread all by
itself no you you put it with stuff
that's the purpose of bread even the
name Triscuit is annoying all right V
we're going to go to the vote here folks
we're back brand new episodes of taste
buds here at the no press Network on
YouTube here we are right out of the
gate with a hot one you want to hear
just a couple of phones want to read a
couple of phones can you real quick read
us a couple Ste see you can you read a
few phones and then V I don't have the
phones I have okay okay V read us a few
phones of your choice okay I'm going to
go with the you have the mic up right
yeah um someone said what is this the
battle of the Great
Depression I would say that about
Triscuits and someone else said trisk
are what middle-aged mothers with
middle-aged children eat because they
are the healthiest for their heart and
by the way I knew this was coming
there's going to there's going to be
only old people eat Triscuits only what
and then other people say weat thins are
for children but adult trisuits yeah I'm
predicting it Wheat Thins for me
Triscuits just remind me of shredded
wheat without the frosting Wheat Thins
are great by themselves or with any type
of dip they're very versatile the
versatility baby you're just talking
cheese there's all sorts of stuff you
can dip that in um we have a lot of
votes for Wheat Thins I'm trying to look
for Triscuits have better flavor someone
said that thank you shout out we have 24
flavors clashy yeah but they're not good
I love both I'll smash this a weat than
Triscuit flavor
bro so step
off um yeah this yeah that's it really
they're all saying they really like uh
wein of course cuz wein is I knew we
you're not giving wein it's due you
could have approached and said I'll give
weens it's due but this is why Triscuits
is better instead what you did is you
revolted against ween and that you'll
find out will be your
undoing all right V give us the vote
okay Humble Pie let's roll it in and we
got the breakdown right now V where you
voting I'm going to vote for Triscuit wo
um it's 43 to 56 Wheat Thins are the
winner wow still close and what's the
what's the uh places on that we have
about um how many votes 43 Point what
4300 votes and we have 43.1 versus 56.9
much closer than I thought it would be
wow that is a lot closer than I thought
I thought trist were going to get
demolished okay so close close close not
too bad I still love you congrats I love
you too congrats on the first win of the
Season that was a good one that was a
good one guys